[Music]
that's olivia rodrigo leaving everyone a
little starry-eyed at the 2021 american
music awards
[Music]
rapper cardi b emceed the ceremony
sunday night and her introduction of
olivia did not disappoint i want to
thank her for mending my heart i love
her i love her so much here's with the
most nominations tonight singing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
olivia's out of this world performance
of trader follows the tracks music video
which dropped last month
[Applause]
[Music]
and get this olivia sort of already won
the night before the show even started
so it's such a big honor the newcomer
was the ama's most nominated artist of
the year with seven noms including
artist of the year favorite female pop
artist and favorite music video for you
know that one catchy song oh and i just
can't imagine how you could be so okay
and olivia had plenty of support from
the red carpet who are you excited to
see tonight i was just saying i'm
excited to see olivia
i love her she's the best e.t caught up
with tate mcrae before the show she gave
some praise to her fellow star on the
rise you guys are such young powerhouses
who have
the brightest futures in this industry
do you guys lean into each other with
that
yeah i mean we're we're good friends and
she's honestly like it's cool because
it's someone i can like talk to and
relate to i mean i think both of us are
perfectionists so it's like put it you
put your own pressure on yourself and so
both of us like want to be the best we
can be and i think that's like for an 18
year old it's a lot and we're like
constantly just like wanting things to
be perfect so i think that's something
that we like relate over while olivia
lost to taylor swift in a couple
categories on sunday sharing the
nominations may have been its own reward
taylor swift i'm the biggest 50 in the
whole world as the singer previously
told et she's kind of a fan i think she
is the most genius songwriter um she
just like works so hard and is such a
storyteller and uses such specificity
and i'm just obsessed with her
you